hey everybody it's me rain wilson and
i'm reza aslan and today oh my gosh
we're gonna have such a special episode
of metaphysical milkshake you can't even
believe it that's right we're gonna go
deep we're gonna get weird we're gonna
search for the meaning
we are not doing that no we're doing
something a little different today okay
okay we could talk about sports no uh no
no i just want you to know that uh your
family
which i have gathered right over here
and i we love you very much reza and
we're a little bit concerned
wait wait wait wait wait what's
happening what's happening okay well you
have a problem and we would like to go
around the circle and tell you how it
makes us all feel oh my god so
is this an intervention
are you doing an intervention
yes i am but we are about what i have no
i have no problems
it's about issues it's about your
twitter use it's a full-on addiction and
it needs to stop come on
i like to tweet that's not an addiction
how many times have you tweeted today
that's not important
how many times
seven
reza
teen
17 18 okay and any of those moments
while you were going to the bathroom
most of them most of them happen while
i'm going to the bathroom but like you
know i go to the bathroom what do you
call that again there's a term for that
swooping it's when you tweet and poop at
the same time you twop look i get bored
okay i can't just sit there and think
about pooping the whole time i have to
do something have you ever accidentally
called your wife jack dorsey during sex
that's not fair she asks me to call her
jack dorsey oh it's a little
role-playing thing okay okay in all
seriousness this does bring up a very
interesting issue and a topic the topic
of addiction
uh it seems like you know whether it's
drugs or alcohol or work or sex or
social media or whatever it is seems
like everybody's addicted to something
everybody yeah so our big question for
uh the pod uh this week why are we
addicted to everything
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
and and this is a topic that is near and
dear to my heart reza is something i've
suffered with i don't talk about it a
whole lot i'm referenced it before but
mental health issues addiction issues
have certainly been with me they've been
with my immediate family my distant
family i've put many many cousins
through various of the finest rehabs in
the country and i'm fascinated by this
topic but again not just like how
addiction works and
on an individual level what addiction is
and and why and what causes it although
that is fascinating and we're going to
get some very valuable perspectives uh
but
humanity seems to be addicted to
everything these days and uh does
humanity just need a giant intervention
like the one we just had for you
yes thank you for that by the way
no this is a this is really fascinating
because i look i'm going to be perfectly
honest with you this is not a topic that
i know a lot about you know i mean i
remember reading
newspapers uh telling me that oh no
don't think of addiction as some kind of
moral failing think of it as a disease
now so i was like okay i'll think of it
as a disease now i guess and then then i
remember you know you would hear these
stories of celebrities being addicted to
to sex or porn and people would you know
make fun of them and i was like well but
if it's a real if it's a disease like
should we be making fun of people for
having cancer like that doesn't it sound
right yeah and it's funny like it seems
like 15 years ago people made fun of
that and nowadays people are just like
people don't know that it's kind of real
i think i think people have changed
people are thinking about addiction
differently but also as you rightly
pointed out
it feels like
everyone's addicted to something now so
like what's going on there this is this
is more than an individual problem this
is a societal problem we need some help
figuring out exactly what the hell is
happening to us and we're not going to
be able to do this ourselves so i have
just
the person
renowned addiction and mental health
specialist dr gabor mate
you love that you never stop talking
about this guy i can't shut up about him
he's a recipient of the hubert evans
nonfiction prize an honorary degree from
university of northern british columbia
i am
i am his biggest fan i'm fangirling out
right now um love his book in the realm
of hungry ghosts close encounters with
addiction let's bring on
dr gabor mate
dr gabor mate welcome to the show
thank you
uh you have excellent hair it's amazing
what toupees will do these days oh
in all seriousness and you've asked us
to call you gabor i am such a huge
fan of your work and it has meant so
much to me over the years i was
profoundly moved by um in the realm of
hungry ghosts
you're kind of
memoir treatise
uh about addiction
and i've seen so many of your talks and
appearances on other people's podcasts
and
your perspective on addiction and the
modern world is like none other
and it has really truly uh touched me
and
i say this
in all seriousness as someone that has
struggled deeply with addiction i had a
lot of mental health issues um i still
do
but a lot more in my 20s is when they
surfaced i had crippling anxiety
i would have anxiety attacks that would
leave me in a pool of sweat on the floor
for years i mean not for years but
over the course of years many of those
and
i suffered from depression and i also
suffered from a lot of addiction issues
and that's not something i talk
a lot about i'm not really a believer in
celebrities sharing every aspect of
their addictive natures but i've
struggled with drugs and alcohol and
that's where it started but i've also
had issues as i've learned more and more
about addiction with
porn and sex i've had issues with uh
gambling um
workaholism
codependence and the list goes on and on
so
i've been in
personally have just loved the process
of being in therapy which i've been in
for a very long time i love that this
you know that excavation of the self and
you know a large part of when you deal
with therapy around addiction is you go
into trauma and that's
you know this link between trauma and
addiction is kind of
where
you live and we're here to ask you some
very big questions about the kind of
totality of the view of addiction and
there really is no better guest on the
planet to have to speak on this topic
and for for those that don't know and
those who are listening who might be a
little bit clueless or have been living
like reza i admit it
totally clueless on this subject and
it's very funny because we reza is so
smart on so many topics and we're
prepping for this and reza's like
i don't know what is it i don't get it
so take us from the very beginning our
first question for you is what is
addiction bring us up to speed well so
let me give you a definition and as i
give it to you just think about it okay
so you might be the one person on the
planet that it doesn't apply to but
an addiction we usually think of it in
terms of drugs and substances but really
as rain was saying
he's got addictions going in a whole lot
of fields
work and sex and substances or whatever
so
addiction is not particularly about
substances an addiction is manifested in
any behavior that a person finds
temporary pleasure or relief in
and therefore craves
but then suffers negative consequences
as a result of and has trouble giving up
despite negative consequences so i said
any behavior so that could be substances
could be tobacco of course alcohol
nicotine opium cocaine whatever it could
be exercise it could be
could be extreme sports could be
exercise social media i guess
social media could be gambling it could
be um shopping
shopping internet gaming eating any
range of human behavior some reason let
me ask you from that point of view and
i'm not going to ask you anything
specific but if i give you that
definition does there being any belts
for you personally
well yeah kind of i mean rain actually
uh at the at the start of this uh
accused me of being a workaholic
and
i guess that's true i am a workaholic i
have you know 14 jobs i have a lot of
kids that i have to feed so that's part
of it but uh but i never really thought
of that as a negative
thing you know well
the question is look at my definition
again the question is does it have
negative consequences on you personally
either physically or emotionally or on
your relationships
yes or no yeah that's the one i'll have
to think about a little bit more see
this is a really fascinating word
because i feel like my knowledge about
addiction really matches kind of
society's changing knowledge right i
like i would say most people i i used to
think addiction was just some kind of
moral failing right it's like if you're
addicted to something you've got a
problem and you should go and and and
fix it and then of course i understood
that that was a misunderstanding and
then i started reading articles that
kept saying no no addiction should be
thought of as a as a disease right it's
like any other disease that you have and
so you have to treat the disease and and
addiction is a disease and you can do
that through therapy or through
medication but what i find fascinating
is that
reading your material your argument is
that it's not a disease it's not a moral
failing it's not a personality trait
there may be some genetic quality to it
but it's not like a a thing where what
we hear all the time well if your dad's
an addict well then you're an addict uh
but that there's something deeper going
on something that does have to do with
with childhood right
well that's what i'm getting at so
that's that um
that's why i'm asking you like maybe
you're one of the few people that
doesn't have an addiction but again i'm
just asking that definition craving and
pleasure relief in the short term
negative consequences and difficulty
giving it up
that's what an addiction is yeah and i
don't i don't get what the target is so
if if if maybe you'd maybe you won't say
maybe you won't identify maybe you're
going to say no i don't have one but i'm
just asking you yes or no you know do i
do i focus on my work sometimes at the
um
detriment of my
relationships absolutely yeah there's no
question about that but but i wonder i
wonder if it's because i'm getting
short-term enjoyment out of it or if
it's because i'm just
scared to death of of being poor again
well here we go to the childhood trauma
piece because reza was sharing with this
with me earlier you know he grew up
super poor parents of immigrants you
know
you've got to work hard to make your way
in this world a lot of pressure and
living in trailer parks and so he's got
14 jobs but isn't that a correlation
between childhood trauma well wait a
minute the 14 jobs could be a rational
decision or it could be an addiction the
question is is there pressure craving
relief in the short term negative
consequence in the long term and does he
have trouble giving it up that's what
the question is it's not what he's doing
it's his relationship to it but let me
ask you this if it's an addiction
what does it do for you in the short
term what do you what do you like about
it and and right i can ask you the same
question whatever addiction processes
you've been through and you've been very
forthright in stating a whole bunch of
them what did they do for you let me ask
you first what did they do for you in
the short term what did you like about
them um
you know to do a deep dive um
my mom left
me no no no no hold on hold on hold on
don't go there yet
but i'm gonna get there i'm gonna get
there i promise there's a reason why i'm
asking in this sequence um in the short
term it allows me to escape anxiety okay
terrific so relief from anxiety is that
a good thing or a bad thing that is a
very good thing excellent
that's what i'm saying is the addiction
is not a disease it's an attempt to
solve a problem the problem is anxiety
so to call it either no did you choose
to be anxious did you wake up one
morning and says hey my ambition is to
be anxious no are you gonna let me share
my childhood trauma yet yeah
in a minute i will but but the point i
want to nail first is the reason
addiction is not a disease or a choice
is because well it really is an attempt
to solve a human problem with emotional
pain okay so the pain comes first so my
mantra is not why the addiction but why
the pain now why the pain
ta-da childhood okay now i can go
now you can go okay so yeah my mom took
off when i was two years old um i was
with my father who did not in any way
have the capacity to take care of a
screaming fat two-year-old white baby he
remarried in a loveless marriage and
moved to central america
as people are want to do in those
circumstances
and um
i
experienced a lot of corporal punishment
and a lot of isolation
and uh over the years uh
you know uh that was that was a fair
amount of trauma in and of itself and it
led to
a lot of anxiety and some depression and
some other issues absolutely so that's
the whole point that you've been itching
to get to very appropriately is that
first comes the trauma
then comes the pain then the addiction
comes along as an attempt to soothe the
pain
so why call it a disease and by the way
even in your narrative it's interesting
how you talked about it you said i
experienced a lot of corporal punishment
no you didn't you were hate a lot
even even to say experience the corporal
punishment is kind of intellectualizing
it
what really happened was you're going to
make me cry
no i'm just teasing but i i do have
emotion around that but no you're
absolutely right i was i was hit a lot
uh as a child yeah and how does that
what's the impact of a child of of being
abandoned by mom
of of of being hit a lot
of being in a marriage
which is love what's the impact it's
tremendous emotional pain and one thing
about addiction it's always an attempt
to escape emotional pain
whether the person realize it or not and
let me tell you i've spoken to
hundreds of people of course they talk
about this all over the world and so on
people say well sometimes that i had a
happy childhood
that usually takes me two minutes
in other words underneath addiction
there's always emotional pain that
emotional pain
is originally rooted in childhood then
it gets triggered in adulthood let's say
you lose a job you lose a marriage let's
say your factory closes down all of a
sudden you lose meaning in your life you
lose a sense of belonging and that's why
we're seeing the rise in addiction these
days so it's not just a question of
individual trauma it's also a question
of social stress in a lot of people
coupled with individual trauma but in
every single case the addictive behavior
whether it's to sex or gambling or
shopping or
substances whatever it is it's always
about trying to soothe some distressing
emotional state so it's not the primary
problem it's an attempt to solve a
problem which then creates more problems
but it's a very it's a very human thing
to do to want to escape emotional pain
hey folks listen today many small
business owners are busier than ever and
time spent searching for and
interviewing the wrong candidates for a
job opening could be time better spent
growing that said business and that is
why linkedin jobs has made it easier to
get to the candidates worth interviewing
faster and you know what it's free reza
you ever had to hire anybody i i have
you know i have to like hire people for
various you know projects that i'm doing
and i'm the worst at it because all i do
is basically like
send texts to friends
anybody know anyone who can do the thing
that i need i mean the idea that i could
just now go to linkedin
where like i got a profile anyway where
it's all full of business people anyway
and just share that find the right
person it's fantastic it's a great idea
you can create a free job post in
minutes on linkedin jobs to reach your
network and beyond to the world's
largest professional network of over 750
million people focus on candidates with
the skills and experience you need use
screening questions to get your role in
front of only the most qualified people
linkedin jobs helps you find the
candidates worth interviewing faster did
you know every week nearly 40 million
job seekers visited linkedin post your
job for free for free at linkedin.com
milkshake that's linkedin.com
milkshake to post your job for free
terms and conditions apply metaphysical
milkshakers this episode is brought to
you by four sigmatic a wellness company
that's well known for its delicious
mushroom coffee i have been starting my
days thanks to
our
little starter kit they sent us with
four sigmatics ground mushroom coffee
with lion's mane instead of regular
coffee and i love how it helps me focus
so i can get [ __ ] done it's amazing and
i definitely feel an uptick in my
productivity every time i drink it
mushroom coffee is also easy on my gut
reza what's your take on on this best
coffee
ever
wow i'm not kidding delicious best
coffee ever yeah it didn't have that
didn't have that uh you know that acidic
thing with the little you know when
sometimes you drink coffee and you can
just feel it going down your chest very
smooth delicious made me feel great we
have worked out an exclusive offer with
our friends at four sigmatic on their
best-selling mushroom coffee but this is
just for metaphysical milkshake
listeners get up to 40 percent off plus
free shipping on mushroom coffee bundles
so to claim this deal you must go to
4sigmatic.com f-o-u-r-s-i-g-m-a-t-i-c
dot com
milkshake this offers only for
metaphysical milkshake listeners and is
not available on their regular website
you'll save up to forty percent get free
shipping so go right now to four
sigmatic dot com slash milkshake and
fuel your productivity and your
creativity with some delicious mushroom
coffee i'm telling you you won't go back
can you just stick a mushroom in your
coffee you stick a mushroom in your
coffee
well look i'm gonna be honest i didn't i
didn't realize that this was gonna be a
therapy session but it is actually
opening up
some things so if i were to answer the
questions that you asked rain
suddenly yes okay if addiction
originates in a person's need to solve a
problem some kind of deep-seated problem
often
having to do with our
earliest years trauma or loss
yeah so
my family was very wealthy when we lived
in iran and then we fled a revolution
and then came here with nothing and grew
up with nothing and
having nothing
was very stressful and it essentially
destroyed our family like you know
destroyed the relationship between my
mother and my father
and
and then you know throughout my 20s and
30s i was fairly poor myself but it
didn't matter because i was sick single
and uh you know whatever when you're
single you could live you could live off
of uh some ramen for for most of your
life for years 29 cents it's easy yeah
um
but you know now i have a wife and i
have more kids than i can count or
recognize sometimes
and
uh
yeah i gotta be honest with you there
now that i think about it
when i
when there is a moment in which i am
unsure of like what the income is going
to be
there is a tightening there is a
tightening in my chest and i do have
kind of flashes
of childhood a little bit
and so
yeah i think uh if yes i guess i am a
workaholic there i i've admitted step
one right the first step is to admit
there's a problem and yeah i think that
i do it
because
i'm so stressed out about being poor
again because i think if we're poor
again it'll destroy my family and my
family's the most important thing to me
and holy [ __ ] i'm an addict
wow
[Laughter]
time to get to a meeting reza
but let me take it a step further okay
so you've recounted the the loss to your
family of the
upheaval in your country having to
immigrate new culture your parents
having to make a living in a totally
different society financially the
economically the pressures on your
family
what did that feel like to you as a
child i'm not talking about the lack of
money i'm talking about the family
atmosphere how did that affect you i
guess the the primary emotion was stress
and anxiety
but the
the
sort of result of the stress and anxiety
was disconnection
okay and that's what trauma is trauma is
a disconnection yeah trauma is a
disconnection himself or from other
people that's what trauma is and and and
there's a good reason for that
disconnection
because when to stay connected is too
painful
the human mind automatically disconnects
and that's what and so that the trauma
is not what happens to us yeah it
happens to us as a result of what
happens what's happening inside us as a
result of what happens to us and that
disconnection that sense of
neither being fully myself or connected
to myself
or
connected with other people the way i
want to be
that's the essence of trauma that
reminds me of like a an animal in the
wild being attacked by a
leopard or something like that and they
and they just lie there sometimes in
their shock and trauma which might be a
defense mechanism but is often uh a rest
response to that negative stimulus well
it's actually a defense mechanism uh in
that frozen state
um the animal doesn't feel as much pain
if it in case it gets attacked
so
animals who can't
escape or fight back which are the which
is the primary
uh defense but if they can't do that
their nervous system goes into freeze
mode which actually is a protective mode
maybe if i'm immobile they won't notice
me and if i am hurt it won't hurt so
much
and uh
people who are traumatized like children
are sexually abused they go into freeze
mode and then they blame themselves
later on why didn't they fight back they
didn't fight back because the nervous
system protected them by going into
freeze mode my family is rife with
addiction so there's just it's
chock-a-block with alcoholics from the
upper middle west of the united states
of america
and that alcohol was the number one kind
of coping mechanism for stress
depression and anxiety especially in the
40s and 50s and 60s so um
but my dad oddly enough
incredibly traumatic childhood i mean
i'm telling you like stories that would
just curdle your blood and curl your
toes
um it mostly did happen a little later
more like 7 8 to 12 13 more in there
um i'm not sure about the trauma in the
earliest chapter of his life but
my dad's surrounded by addicts um
he didn't drink he didn't smoke uh he
didn't overeat he didn't overwork
i mean
uh you know i suppose i mean he had some
character defects that one could point
to as a trauma response like he had a
tendency to be very passive in his life
and kind of not proactively make
decisions that would help him um he
would get kind of choose not great
marriage partners he was married four
times although his his last wife he had
was was wonderful um
he passed away by the way uh earlier
this year let me ask you what is the
personality
79
or what disease
a heart disease
um
really bad heart disease
totally clogged arteries and they tried
to do a quadruple bypass and it it
didn't take what makes you sure that the
heart disease wasn't the trauma effect
and see i'm not say i'm not saying that
everybody was traumatized becomes
addicted
what i said was that everybody was
addicted was traumatized
but trauma can show up in different ways
for example
a canadian study men who are sexually
abused
they have a significantly higher risk of
of heart disease whether they smoke or
not or whether they drink or not so that
so that there's all kinds of ways
physiologically image trauma potentiates
heart disease your father's heart
disease i would suggest it's probably a
trauma effect
no he didn't have addiction but again
trauma can manifest in multiple ways
addiction being only one of them
ah so you know you talk about these
things uh that you referred to as
adverse childhood experiences right or c
e so this is we've talked a little bit
about this uh you know abuse or
violence in the family um the extreme
stress of poverty which is something
that i i experienced
uh maybe like a really bad divorce or
parents who are an addict um
and you're saying that
you can sort of trace this that you can
you can look at people who have a high
number of these ace
and how
it it's sort of a straight line it
exponentially increases their chances of
becoming an addict later on right
yeah but not just being an addict also
the chances of having uh autoimmune
disease malignancy mental illness all
kinds of things
so
the line between aces is not directly
only exclusively with addiction is to
all man over afflictions uh also like
suicide early death things like that
all that yeah yeah
sexually transmitted disease everything
so you know not to get too personal but
obviously you've shared this before but
you had of course a very uh traumatic uh
childhood uh your uh
parents uh lived under nazi rule
um
i wonder like how
that experience shaped your
um addiction theories first of all
my addiction theories are grounded in
science they're not just the insights
that i've had in other words sure what
what there's a huge gap in medical
practice is between what science has
shown us and what doctors understand i
mean
what i'm talking about has only been
shown in 10 000 studies you know which i
have many of them on my computer they
should be in trauma and addiction how
trauma affects the brain i don't make
that stuff up
it's only that
i saw its impact in physical in clinical
practice that couldn't help it right but
you also have a personal experience of
it as well not just a clinical one well
that's right and and so
in terms of my own experience um when i
was working here in vancouver with a
highly addictive population people that
were dependent on heroin and cocaine and
crystal meth and all manner of
substances
they're all been severely traumatized
and i didn't have ever
have a substance addiction but i had
some significant behavioral addictions
including to work into shopping and i
would lie and cheat and uh manipulate
just like my addictive clients that was
you know
and and and
it had impacts on my personal life and
my marriage and my children and so on
so i could easily recognize the
similarities between myself and my
clients now they are the differences
were obvious i was a middle class
successful physician they were street
dwellers they had hiv i didn't
but but in terms of the similar so the
differences are obvious but it was the
similarities that were interesting
and
now when you said at a traumatic
childhood
i want to correct that a little bit
i didn't have the kind of traumatic
childhood that reign had
i had traumatic infancy
but the family i grew up in
was
by and large a functional
[Music]
loving family home my parents were not
perfect friends
but there was no
neglect or abuse of our skin so that the
trauma that i sustained
happened in the first year of my life
with the jewish infant on the nazi
occupation under the threat of genocide
the privation the hunger separation from
my mother that has significant impacts
on my brain
it it made me tune out as a way of
coping with it so i develop add which by
the way is not another non-disease that
they think is a disease but actually it
begins as a tuning
and so i had the tuning out i had poor
impulse regulation i was a kind of a
symptom of emptiness and and not being
enough
now if you don't think you're enough
here's what you do you go to medical
school and and and now you're gonna
uh if you don't think you're lovable go
to medical school if you don't think
they want you yeah
like my mother gives me a stranger as a
year one year old to save my life so i
don't day for six don't steer for six
weeks well the message i get is i'm not
wanted okay
and now if you're not wanted to go to
medical school as i've often said no
they're gonna want you all the time uh
when you when they're dying when they're
being born and every minute in between
when there's a crisis highly addictive
so there's my work addiction
yeah
so that my infancy
and the unresolved pain i was carrying
as a result of it
really had a lot to do with the stresses
in my marriage the trauma that i
transmitted to my children
i approached my work and all that and of
course
working on all that stuff
like rain at some point i had to decide
hey this life is not working
i need to find out why i need to go in
therapy i need to do some self
reflection
and that's when i started to put these
pieces together and it resonated so much
with the experiences of my clients
the difference being that they had had
much tougher childhoods than i had
this podcast is sponsored by better help
folks therapy is uh such an important
tool and uh
people talk about oh it's so much money
i can't afford it but you know what it's
an investment in yourself and yes you're
you know you're paying in those hundreds
of dollars and i know times are tough
and money is tight but it can really pay
off further down the line if you're not
getting in your own way and shooting
yourself in the foot learning how to
believe in yourself better and getting
out of dangerous patterns that hold you
back i have been a huge huge fan of
therapy for the last 20 years and this
is a great way to do it better help is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches that make it easy
and free to change counselors if you
need and it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
there's financial aid so betterhelp
wants you to start living a happier life
today it's a worldwide service you can
log into your account anytime you can
send a message to your counselor
why not try it here's what i'm going to
ask people to do visit betterhelp.com
milkshake that's better b-e-t-t-e-r help
h-e-l-p
not better kelp
that's a different product and join the
over one million people who have taken
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional in
fact so many people have been using
better help that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
special offer for metaphysical milkshake
listeners get 10 off your first month
at betterhelp.com
milkshake green chef makes it easy to
eat the immune boosting foods you need
to stay healthy and fuel a jam-packed
end to summer eating well is easier than
ever with satisfying home-cooked dinners
and options that work around your
lifestyle not the other way around you
can choose from 30 easy to follow
recipes every week with options for keto
paleo plant-powered diets whatever
you're doing listen i've tried other
meal preparation services and i really
liked green chef because
everything was really organic and super
fresh and really healthy and you can
taste that in every bite i had this like
moroccan
rice
no moroccan couscous and vegetables dish
it was delicious it was spiced and
flavored perfectly and i
highly recommend it so go to green chef
dot com slash milkshake 100 and use code
milkshake 100 to get guess how much 100
off
including free shipping that's green
chef dot com
slash milkshake 100 and you get 100 off
including free shipping green chef the
number one meal kit for eating well i
feel like milkshake 100 should be the
name of our band i like that
what what would you be the the lead
singer is that of course of course if i
get to take my shirt off yes and what
i'd be the roadie is that what is that
tambourine
you know you you talked about this seems
like a modern part of the disease i mean
it's probably been throughout human
history but a more modern part of the
disease are
stressed out busy parents who are unable
to be there for their kids or unwilling
or just dealing with their own addiction
you know i'm raising a teenage boy um
and
you know it seems like there's so much
more to navigate these days like if you
go back to like the 50s and 60s what are
the addictions like well it's cocktails
like mad men and then some really bad
folks that get into some
heroin yeah but that wasn't even
considered an addiction and then that
was later and then all of a sudden
there's
you know uh you you can add on oh
there's
you know lighter drugs like marijuana
but then maybe i don't know
sex and shopping and gambling and you
know it starts to kind of compound but
now in raising a teenager
and i look around and i see
so many
dangers that just didn't exist you know
the idea that you can pick up this phone
and then there's uh
a uh
there's a thousand video games on it you
know um vaping is happening non-stop
with teenagers uh
social media obviously we've talked
about kind of
unlimited porn i mean you know we put
blocks on the phone and stuff like that
but porn is just ubiquitous and
everywhere we had to fight like hell for
our playboy magazines in the 1970s to
even get like three wrinkled magazines
to look at furtively now it's just like
anything you want pornography wise is
just available sugar is in everything
and way more available than it used to
be constant distraction i even had a
friend of a friend whose kids
were
put into therapy for youtube addiction
very specifically inability to stop
looking at youtube videos you talked
about these short term so there's this
kind of this this ladder this evolution
of addiction that seems to be coming on
more and more and more fronts can you
talk about this this modern battle we've
got going on
well there's a number of things going on
i mean you absolutely write in your
description um the number of things
driving it number one
we're not raising kids like the way
human kids are meant to be raised
even kids are meant to be raised in
large family hunter-gatherer tribal
groupings with lots of nurturing adults
around
free play in nature and companions of
multiple ages infants were not meant to
be put down they were meant to be held
all the time they were not meant to cry
it out they were meant to be sued right
away this is how human beings evolved so
we've come up far away now the average
in the united states at least
25 percent of women have to go back to
work within two weeks they're giving
birth wow which is a major trauma to the
infant the loss of the mother
even the temporary loss of the mother
because you know whenever and how to
gather goods the average age of weaning
from breastfeeding is four years
so we've we've gone way beyond the niche
in which we evolved that's hurting a lot
of kids that creates a lot of emptiness
and pain in children and then the
society creates a lot of modalities to
wish to soothe the pain to distract
ourselves from it this being a major
culprit the cell phone the television
the youtube the internet um another
thing uh rain if you're raising teenager
i really urge you to read the book i
co-wrote but hold on to your kids if you
haven't read it write this down hold on
to your kids because what happens
the human brain
can't handle
a loss of
relationship so when a duckling hatches
from the egg i'm going to go a bit of a
rant for a minute here
when the duckling hatches from the egg
what what happens when the when the
duckling sees the mother duck what do we
call that imprinting exactly and
imprinting is i'm going to follow you
and i'm going to be your child and your
follower and you're going to teach me
and protect me and nurture me now what
happens to duckling if it hatches from
the egg and the mother duck is not there
what will the duckling imprint on
whatever's there yeah whatever exactly
whatever whatever is there could be a
dog a horse a mechanical moving toy none
of which are designed by nature to bring
that duckling up to adulthood now
children are the same children are meant
to imprint on the parents and the
nurturing adults but what happens in our
society our children from an early john
daughter and see don't even see the
adults in their lives most of the day
who did they imprint on do you think in
each other
so now you have immature creatures
imprinting on other immature creatures
ah
and when that happens
kids are desperate to connect to each
other all the time through this thing
here isn't that just called instagram
yeah immature creatures imprinting on
other immature creatures
absolutely absolutely absolutely and
that's the sideline so what i'm saying
is that first of all this society
creates the problem and then it creates
products to exploit the problem and so
that and and when kids imprint on each
other parents lose their capacity to
parent they lose their power because the
kids are not looking to the parent
anymore
so it's a huge problem so there's so
many ways image to society a creates
problems and then
in its ingeniousness creates products to
exploit the problem and the food you
mentioned sugar you know this the food
companies do special research high
sophisticated neural research
neurological research to figure out what
combination of sugar salt and fat will
be most addictive to children yeah and
that same process is undertaken by
psychologists that work for social media
companies that try and
monetize dopamine hits there are teams
of specialists trying to keep us and get
us addicted i know that's the whole
point so the society creates the
emptiness and the pain and the stress
and then it creates products to exploit
it for profit now in the downtown east
of vancouver if a patient of mine sold
an ounce of cocaine
they'd be sitting in jail
but these people sit in corporate
boardrooms addicting millions of people
to health endangering behaviors
and all they do is get higher um
dividends
that's the society that we live in
in a sense you've kind of answered
already our big question in this episode
why are we addicted to everything
addiction
numbers in the u.s uh are skyrocketing i
have some stats here which right away i
don't even believe them 38 percent of
adults battled an illicit drug
use disorder that's way too low
almost 21 million americans have at
least one addiction [ __ ] that's way
too low now that i think about it that's
because they define addiction in very
narrow terms yeah drugs and alcohol
that's what they that's what they're
saying right uh only 10 of them uh
receive treatment uh about 300 million
people throughout the world have an
alcohol use disorder no it's way higher
no way these are these yeah these these
numbers it's way
but the bottom line is is that
the answer to the question why are we
addicted to everything
seems to be that well if addiction is a
symptom of a disorder and the disorder
is trauma that comes from
a inc
growing up in an increasingly
disconnected
de-spiritualized world well then there's
your answer
so
you know at the risk of uh
depressing the [ __ ] out of all of our
listeners uh
what
where do you find hope how do we how do
we heal ourselves uh as a society well
first of all uh
my intention is not exactly to depress
anybody
it's actually show them that a different
possibility is available to us you know
but we have to first get the reality of
this
life that we're living what i love doing
though is disillusioning people now we
think of we think of disillusionment as
a bad thing but let me ask you something
would you rather be illusioned or this
illusion how would you rather be
i'd rather be living in reality you'd
love to believe in reality because you
can't grow unless you're seeing it
that's the whole point and so
i
my intention is never to depress but
it's always to hold up a reflection of
reality to people no
it's not a question of hope
or something happening in the future
i believe deeply
uh
in in the human capacity for wholeness
by the way healing comes from the word
wholeness
so and that disconnection is a loss of
wholeness but it's not the loss of
wholeness in the sense of the wholeness
being destroyed it just we lose
connection with our wholeness so i
believe in the possibility of
reconnection what we call reconnection
regarding recovery finding against
something that we've lost and so that
possibility is inherent in every human
being and every creature in the universe
by the way
so
when you ask me what's the hope the
possibility of reconnection
and healing is available to us as long
as we're alive so it's not this
vague hope that i have it's a real
possibility that i've seen in action
uh inspiringly so and and it can happen
both on the individual
and with much more great difficulty on
the social level as well so he asked me
what's my hope well that's the
possibility that i see
[Music]
that is a perfect way to end this
discussion but we have a cherry on top
of the pie
um i don't know what you say in um in
vancouver british columbia we've got a
cinnamon on top of the crumpet
the gravy on top of the fries the gravy
on the poutine is the lightning round
we're going to ask you quick fire
questions we'd love to hear the first
response that comes to your mind helps
us get to know you a little bit better
and shed some insights so
uh gabor when do you feel most connected
with the universe when i look at my
wife's eyes
oh i love that
uh what skill do you wish you had
drumming i wish i was a great drummer we
should hang i'm not great but i'm pretty
i can pound you know what i mean i can
pound my six-year-old kicks ass anyway
what was the happiest day of your life
the day my first child was born that was
the happiest moment of my life what's
something that uh only few people know
about you what a wonderful guy i am
we know that brandon and i did that
wayne i've known that for years what
book changed your life
don quixote that's the first cervantes
uh yeah reference so far yeah
tell us about your most enlightening
spiritual experience but it can't be
look into your wife's eyes or your birth
of your child it happened in the
influence actually of um of ayahuasca
there we go
a peruvian
or amazonian
brew
administered by shamans
and as the shaman was chanting to me
two years ago in the deep in the jungle
of peru
i had this
can't even describe experience
well you can you say i can't even
describe experience can you
give us a try give it a try three
sentences
what can you describe because that's
that's a big setup well it was a
sky blue screen i was looking at might
have been the sky
and
inscribed in that sky
in cloud like letters
were
was a word made up of six characters
b-o-l-d-o
which is the hungarian word for happy
and all sudden i realized
that my happiness is not dependent
is not limited by what happened to me as
an infant
damn all right our final question that
we always ask is what is your life's big
question
you know
when i go into the depths of me
there are no questions left
and
that doesn't mean that i won't get
surprised i expect to be surprised
but something in me already knows what
surprise is going to be
that's as close as i can get to it dr
government this has been uh
one of the most fascinating
pods i think we've ever done certainly
for me now that i
know that apparently i'm an addict and i
should probably think about that a
little bit more
so if nothing else has come out of this
yeah exactly so we've uncovered reza's
addiction just inspiring an amazing
conversation as i knew it would be and
um
i just urge all the listeners to um
well to call you to call and email you
and he's in vancouver if you wander
around the streets of vancouver you'll
run into uh yeah yeah
i hope they don't but they can certainly
check out my website and
and there's a lot of my work on the
youtube on on youtube that nobody has to
pay any money to access yes and unless
you're addicted to youtube you should
avail yourself
except for that kid who's addicted to
youtube wherever you are thank you very
much uh gabor mate uh for being on
metaphysical milkshake uh we certainly
appreciate it
thank you
wow that was powerful man um i feel like
i owe him money for therapy you should
absolutely be paying him like
375 dollars that's the high-end therapy
rate what kind of a therapist are you
seeing that's a high-end therapy rate
that's what celebrities pay for yes
celebrity celebrity therapist that
sounds like a a fun comedy like
al hatchet celebrity therapist
is your newborn um but that was amazing
what did you what did you get out of
that conversation it seems i saw i've
known you for a long time i saw a lot of
light bulbs going i know right it does
it's rare that i learned something
or it's really certainly rare that i
learned something about myself but uh
first of all i want to say
his
his definition of what addiction is
makes the most sense to me because i
mean as i as i said earlier i'm kind of
i've been confused about what i hear
like are things not addictive but people
are addictive but actually it turns out
things are kind of addictive and maybe
it's a disease and maybe it's not a
disease and maybe it's something you
inherit but maybe it has to do with your
circumstances like i
and his definition of it that well it's
both biological and psychological and
environmental because it it's all this
kind of cycle that happens a cycle of
trauma makes so much sense to me
and using that framework
to really think about why it is that i
work so [ __ ] hard all the time
and expect people to praise me for it
you know like yeah i expect people to be
like holy [ __ ] reza you're amazing like
you know
but
is it
the symptom
of a
trauma that i've never
actually really dealt with for sure
is it
trying to
fix
some anxiety that shows up every once in
a while and that i can immediately bury
down by taking another gig yeah
does it
come with some long-term consequences in
this particular case
not spending as much time as i could
with my kids yeah holy [ __ ]
right right oh my god like yeah
so the you know the question that uh my
therapist would ask and i imagine that
gabor would ask as well is like okay so
you have this anxiety and fear
of deprivation that came from
deprivation and trauma
and
you try and soothe that or assuage that
fear
with uh working taking on new projects
that take you away from your family so
what are you going to do to soothe
yourself to calm your anxiety to escape
your pain that are healthy that don't
involve something that's going to have
some kind of deleterious effect on you
or your family
no [ __ ] wrong pickleball
no pickleball beach volleyball
okay maybe okay all right all right i'm
just i'm just thinking out loud here
dear listener so so bear with me
maybe i should have a hobby like the one
thing that my friends know about me that
my wife makes fun of me all the time is
that i literally don't have a hobby with
the exception
of the now unfortunately las vegas
raiders
oh i i i don't have a hobby i literally
chickens have a hobby that's not a hobby
it uh it feeds my kids eggs so i don't
have to buy eggs i've got a good hobby
for you
beekeeping
i i got beat we had
long longtime listeners no it didn't
work out we tried the bee thing go back
we killed 20 000 bees
maybe that's just it maybe what i need
to do is find myself a hobby
something that doesn't pay
like i feel like everything that i do is
essentially a job because i'm constantly
we've talked about this before because
part of my thing is being an actor and
being in public and a public figure like
everything i do like if even if i learn
a song in guitar i'll be like oh i'm to
put this on my instagram right you know
everything is for show it's for the show
and one of the things i've wanted to do
is i've always loved uh pottery and
ceramics i got a kiln and kind of
setting up an area in my garage to do it
and
uh you know i think i need to do it and
not show anything on instagram like i
need to just you don't want to seth
rogen it
no no no [ __ ] that i need to i need to
have my own private idaho of my
of my of my work
and
you know is it something that can soothe
me and uh
and and quell some anxiety maybe so same
thing without with me in books
so people are always like have you read
this book it's really entertaining and
i'm like i don't read books to be
entertained
i read books to learn [ __ ] so that i can
do other things so you can sound smart
on podcasts
by referencing them even novels i'm like
well i i will read only certain novels
if it helps me be a better writer but i
would never read a novel cause i enjoy
it like that's not a thing that i would
do
my son gave me a book
red
red planet rising or something like that
it's an action-adventure book about a
revolution on mars in the future oh [ __ ]
i read that
but i did but again only because it was
possible that i was thinking of maybe
joining a group of people who were going
to adapt it i would never have read it
so my son is employing me to just read
it because it's so freaking awesome
so i'm gonna sit down and read a book
for pleasure so there you go
what about you dear
listener uh certainly if you went
through the same experience that i did
you
probably have learned something about
yourself do you
have an addiction that you were unaware
of until this moment are you someone
with addictions uh that you recognize
but never really understood uh the
trauma behind them let us know
so you know rayne we had asked our
loyal fans and listeners
that if they could
go to wherever they listen to
our podcast apple spotify wherever
rate and review us
and write down sort of a life's big
question and that if we really liked it
we would have them come on the show and
we'd give them the opportunity to ask us
in person and we would answer it solve
all of their problems and no one no one
did it did they no one did it
one person did it no i'm just kidding a
lot of people
thousands
of people did it but
millions like rogan's size audience did
it no are you nuts no is it roganesque
maybe like
the people in the studio while rogan
does his podcast like that we need to
talk about uh mushrooms and wrestling
more somebody write that hey let's get
in a podcast battle with joe rogan
have you seen he's got muscles i don't
he could take both of us plus he's he's
not vaccinated i don't want to be
anywhere near him so someone wrote in is
what you're saying lots of people wrote
in
one person one is what i'm trying to say
wow it was a winner and that winner is
here with us and her name is ren morton
and she's joining us from lawrenceville
kansas hi ren
hi thank you for having me
hi wren welcome to metaphysical
milkshake thank you for posting your
question and your review so beautifully
on the apple podcasts app and what is
ren does ren stand for like renaissance
that's a nickname my nickname is little
renaissance um but it's short for my
middle name renee well first let me make
sure to introduce the two of you ren
rain rain ren ren rain nice to meet you
my question was
should belief systems be legitimized
in the sense of being considered
sanctioned or genuine
or legit
basically um
you know when i i've studied a lot i i
grew up fundamental baptist
as i think most kansans probably tend
towards and then
um he had a heartbreak with christianity
and i spent a year in the mosque a year
in the zen center two years in a
catholic center
um i've studied hindu mythology buddhism
um before settling were you locked in
these centers did they lock you in the
in the zen center i spent a year
let me out of here
i cannot take the koans anymore
yes it's just more in the sense of just
attending regularly and
and being a part of that community for a
while and
um i just noticed that you know
uh christianity islam
uh and many of the others tend to throw
their weight behind their 2000 year old
religions
and they're um
you know i i wonder sometimes how that
works for other belief systems that were
interrupted by violence and colonialism
and how they regain that legitimacy um
you know there's a conversation around
reclaiming what was lost and destroyed
and that i think plays into that claim
for legitimacy
um but
you know in in witchcraft and and
feminine-centered belief systems there's
a lot of controversy about choosing
goddesses and the legitimacy of that and
the naming of goddesses and things like
that
and um so it just makes me think about
you know should should that even be a
thing like is
is should there be a commentary on
whether or not someone's belief system
is legitimate
wow first of all can i thank you for not
for coming on and not talking about the
i just office want to appreciate that
listen this we love this question don't
we rain i mean
you know systems and legit where do they
gain their legitimacy from that's a very
you know interesting important issue it
does legitimacy come from the number of
followers
um does it come from how long the belief
system
um has existed i mean you're absolutely
right rain has heard me tell this joke a
million times but the difference between
a religion and a cult is time that's it
that's the that's the difference between
those you know we always we joke that
cult plus time equals religion
but how much certainly christianity was
considered a cult in its first couple
hundred years who are these crazy people
and the son of god and he floated up to
the sky and what are these morons
talking about i mean they sold all their
possessions and lived in common together
like that's
a call that's crazy and then all of a
sudden
there's a caesar sounds very familiar
he converts and then it's the state
religion and then they're off to the
races but then the other thing too is
like well isn't is it number of
believers and that's kind of an
interesting
thought experiment as well i mean you
think about judaism which is an ancient
religion but which has
12 to 15 million followers in the world
um you know that's how many hindus you
know are just at my local bodega um so
you know it's again it's it's hard it's
hard to figure out where this legitimacy
goes i have my kind of idea about
where
legitimacy
rests and i think it's it has to do with
how a belief system
can use the language of metaphor the
language of symbols to address
the
constantly changing situation
of its believers and that constantly
changing thing is really important like
any anybody who has studied the world
religions will tell you that the
difference between a living religion and
a dead religion
isn't that one is true and one is not
true the difference is is that one
evolved and one didn't
if if a belief system is incapable
of
constant malleability constantly
changing constantly evolving
to match the
ever-changing needs of the community
that religion goes away and there are
hundreds if not thousands of examples of
religions that
at one time you know
crisscross the entire globe
zoroastrianism one of my all-time
favorite religions the perfect example
of this right i mean
zoroastrianism was one time the largest
empire in the world and now there are
maybe a couple of hundred thousand
zoroastrians left well because one of
the laws of zoroastrianism is they're
not allowed to convert anyone that's
what i was gonna say yeah you can't
declare your faith wren morton couldn't
spend a year at the zoroastrian center
they'd they wouldn't let her in what
about manichaeism was just as big as
christianity in early and early rome and
uh complete completely disappeared
manicka is a much influenced by
zoroastrianism but i think there's a
there's another aspect to this question
which is
and this you know philosophy deals with
this a lot it's the difference between
subjective truth and objective truth so
at the end of the day we're all gonna
die and we'll we'll either kind of like
wake up in some other state of being
with some kind of conscious some kind of
consciousness and some other altered
state and recognize that there is some
kind of divine creator out there or it
will just be lights out and we're all
just a random assemblage of molecules
and so one of the or the other of those
is true and there's probably some ground
in them we may wake up and be we're all
in hell and it's jesus is the son of god
and because we're not born again and we
weren't baptized in a certain way that
we're going to burn in hell for eternity
so that's an objective truth one of
those things is going to exist out there
but what you're talking about is the
subjective truth coming into creation of
a belief system and that gets very um
delicate you're right because for
hundreds of years thousands of years
these
larger belief systems kind of squashed
and quelled other smaller belief systems
and delegitimized them
and in many cases absorb them too
so
yeah and then the other the other thing
i'll say is that you know with regard to
you were talking about
you know wicca and nature religions and
things like that and i think oftentimes
people tend to think of those as
new religions or new ideas or that it's
somehow innovative to think of
the feminine aspect of god you know
instead of the masculine aspect and yes
it is true that for a few thousand years
god the father has been the dominant
um you know metaphor for the way that
particularly we in the west think of the
divine
but for about a hundred thousand years
before then
god the mother was ascendant so again if
we're talking about how long a
you know a belief system lasts and
whether that's where its legitimacy lies
then certainly polytheism is way more
legitimate than monotheism monotheism is
barely 5 000 years old um you know
certainly
concepts of the divine mother as opposed
to divine father are much older
nature religions are much much older so
you know again to me it is that
subjective truth that that rain was
talking about you know even in the term
belief system
implied within that term is subjectivity
and so it really is about
what answers your questions right what
allows you
to
have a view of the world that makes
sense that that allows you to to
understand what your role in this kind
of indeterminate existence is that's
what i find interesting is like
witchcraft we
we're not evangelicals like we have no
interest in converging converting
anybody and so witches don't generally
talk about it um and so it's always kind
of like a surprise if you find someone
like in your environment that has like
the same like set of belief you're like
oh okay that that um that's so
interesting that we kind of came to that
and so for me like the concept of it is
more focused on like the loss of the
tricks of the trade that were shared
among women the way that
you know the
the
i guess the esoteric concepts were baked
into nursery rhymes and to hymns and you
know it was really
um a place at the earth and rather and
rather than at these like huge
dominating
um structures
and so um
that made more sense to me and i liked i
like the fluidity of the bully system
you know
witches tend very much to be like we're
very nonjudgmental about
if someone has an experience that
differs from ours we're like that could
totally be a thing just because it's not
our experience doesn't mean it doesn't
exist
and so i think there's a lot for me that
which is always new that science is just
catching up to
for example
um i'm also a synesthete and i have
what's called emotional
mediated synesthesia
so you see feelings
i see fillings in color and i can taste
them
and so
what science is now discovering is that
that is
like my brain just has more mirror
neurons
than other people's brains
and for which is we always knew this
existed you know they're called empaths
or they're called auras
um but you know for a long time that was
like that's like
you know that's metaphysics
um
you know in the book section now my main
question is does the state of kansas
know that it's employing a wiccan who
can taste feelings
no
but i also i'm not afraid um
you know i think that
i i don't proselytize like i said which
is don't proselytize but i'm i'm not
afraid of repercussions so well listen
ren thank you so much for joining us uh
fascinating discussion great question
thanks for leaving your
question in the comments section of the
apple podcast and anyone else can do
that as well and perhaps we will invite
you on the show like we did to wren
morton the kansas
witch of lawrence
you can find us on socials reza aslan
rayne wilson we're on twitter
metamilkpodcast
and on instagram metaphysicalmilkshake
tag us let us know
and if you want to watch our faces
talking uh check us out on our youtube
channel and subscribe their metaphysical
milkshake youtube channel if you are
going to be addicted
to anything
being addicted to this podcast isn't so
bad i'm totally addicted to metaphysical
milkshakes oh my god you guys dr gabriel
mate said share that with your friends
uh rate like subscribe review our
podcast please give us five star on
apple podcast and talk about how much
you love us and that will actually help
us uh in the podcast world and it will
also
validate our workaholism thank you for
listening everyone see you next time
[Music]
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samazadeh yazd harris lane mick demaria
hashem self and dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner it is edited by
tyler newbold an audio mixed by justin
kyle original music by jeff tang
you know the buddha 2500 years ago talk
about being people being addicted to
games and elephant shows and all you
know i too am addicted to elephant shows
but i love elephant shows i will drop
anything to go to an elephant show